hi everyone welcome to the sixth
tutorial in our imaging science series
here at the MIT Museum for today's video
we have a special guest
Jeffrey Kuhn who is the scientific
director of the Koch Institute
microscopy core facility here at MIT and
he's going to discuss what exactly is a
digital image and how we can use that
knowledge to make adjustments to those
images and to show things that we
wouldn't have otherwise seen and with
that I'm gonna hand it over to Jeffrey
in this video we're going to be talking
about scientific images some of the most
important features of them and how you
process them I'm going to give you a
little bit of background information
first on what scientific images are and
some of the basic features that we are
going to need to understand in order to
bring out more information from these
images
so what are the main things we look for
in a scientific image well the first
thing we look for is whether or not you
can see what you want to see this is
dictated by the contrast whether
something is visible in the first place
we also want to know if we have enough
information to see to distinguish things
and that's resolution and we typically
think of resolution in terms of
megapixels in your camera but there's a
scientific definition of resolution that
is can you distinguish two things as
separate or not there's also how much
uncertainty there is in your measurement
how clear your images and every
measurement you take has uncertainty if
you measure the temperature over the
course of a day your uncertainty might
be a few degrees Fahrenheit so images
are no different there is an uncertainty
in the measurement of intensities of an
image and in imaging we use the
signal-to-noise ratio if noise is the
uncertainty in your measurement the
signal is what you want to see we tend
to measure the ratio between those two
things to tell us how clear our
certainty is and then finally there's
the speed of which in which you take an
image that's called temporal resolution
so did you capture the right moment in
time
so you can't have good contrast good
resolution good clarity and fast speeds
all at once there's always a compromise
between these factors there's always a
balance you have to make and this is
called the triangle of compromise so for
instance if you want something that's
both bright and high resolution in
detail you'll have to image very slowly
if you want something that very fast
imaging and high resolution you'll have
to you won't be able to collect as much
light it's going to be dimmer if you
want something that's bright and fast
you're going to have to sacrifice
spatial resolution and you'll but you'll
end up with a blockier image
we can however balance between these
factors for most cameras you can set the
exposure time for your images so if you
want to do a fast exposure to capture
fine motion you can do that but you'll
be getting a dimmer image and you might
have to sacrifice some detail if you
want slower images you can make them
brighter some cameras let you actually
change the resolution of the image
basically putting a bunch of pixels
together into big super pixels and that
actually increases the sensor area the
pixels makes them brighter so you can
get at the expense of lower resolution
you can get a brighter image or if you
want higher resolution you're going to
deal with dimmer or less light
collecting ability also you can bounce
between these things by expense so
bigger sensors and bigger lenses that
can collect more light but that ends up
being more expensive so the camera
equipment that you use can dictate how
far along this triangle of compromise
you can go so digital image is
fundamentally a matrix of numbers that
describe intensities so we're going to
use this image of an old world a mandrel
to talk about the numbers that make up
the intensities in an image and we're
going to ignore color for the time being
and just look at a black and white
version of this mandrel so let's take a
look at a little tiny portion of the
muzzle near this little red line on the
muzzle and if we blow up that little
portion that looks like a bunch of gray
squares and those gray squares make up
are made up of a bunch of numbers and if
you look the squares on the left-hand
side tend to be a little bit higher
value let's say 180-200 things like that
then those images are brighter those
pixels are brighter the ones on the
right-hand side are a little bit lower
value 111 118 they tend to be darker so
the numbers in this matrix describe
intensities so how do computers
represent numbers well we represent
numbers the Arabic way or in powers of
10 and decimal digits so for instance a
three-digit number has ones place a tens
place and
it's place and for example the number
136 is a one in a hundreds place a three
in the tens place and a six in the ones
place units um all those together a
hundred plus 30 plus 6 and that gives
you 136 well computers represent numbers
in a binary fashion so they use a single
number between 0 0 or 1 to describe a
number and each of these bits can go
from 0 1 and they have different places
in ones place a twos place a fours place
etc so for instance the number one can
be represented by a one in the ones
place and zero everywhere else the
number 136 can be represented by a
number one in the 128 place and a one in
the 8th place and that adds together to
be 136 if you have all ones in one of
these 8-bit values the maximum number is
255 so eight bits can have a maximum of
255 in a minimum of 0 and it turns out
the more bits you use in one of these
images the more shades of gray you can
represent so for instance a two bits can
represent four different shades of grain
so here's the mandrill with four shades
of gray you can also use four bits or 16
shades of gray and now we're starting to
get a little bit more detail on this
mandrel it doesn't look quite so chunky
8 bits gives you 256 shades of gray and
now this mandrel looks very smooth very
good detail in this mandrel but
computers and sometimes scientific
images can actually take even more than
8 bits they might have 16 bits of images
of numbers in your image so 65,000
shades or you might use color where in
most cases most computers will use 8
bits per color so 256 shades of red 256
shades of green 256 shades of blue let's
look now at the difference between 8 and
4 bits let's zoom up on a little bit of
a portion of this now if you notice in
the 4 bit image you can see the
gradations from gray to white in the
muzzle
whereas with 256 shades you can't really
see much of a gradation at all it looks
much smoother so it turned out somewhere
between that 16 shades
256 shades is about where your eyes can
distinguish individual shades of gray so
what makes a good image these are
examples of cells taken by microscopes
and most of these have slightly
different contrasts and it's the
contrast that makes them better or worse
so for example the cells on the top
left-hand side the top left in the top
middle are taken with the same
microscope using different contrast
methods in this top left image you could
barely start to see some cells and in
the middle image you can actually make
them out because they've got higher
contrast
similarly this image of a cell on the
right hand side has pretty good contrast
as well not quite as good as the one in
the middle and then in the bottom row
you're seeing good contrast between the
two bottom images you're getting nice
these are called microtubules they're
very bright against a dark background
and the one in the middle is less blurry
than the one on the left hand side so
blurring it makes a little less or worse
contrast and then finally color can add
additional detail of contrast for your
eye so let's talk about contrast
contrast is whether or not you can see
something in the first place so I've
drawn a bunch of dots on this slide and
those represent a signal a signal that
we want and I put them on top of
different backgrounds and the background
is what we don't care about or what we
don't really want so I've increased the
signal from going from left to right
hand side and I've increased more and
more background going from top to bottom
so let's take a look at the left hand
side the weakest signal you can actually
start to see this weak signal on top of
a black background but when you've got a
really bright or white background that
signal is almost gone and it turns out
the definition of contrast is
essentially the signal you want to - the
background you don't care about / the
background so but intuitively what we
think about is that the more background
you have the weaker the contrast the
more signal you have the higher the
contrast so the contrast increases from
left to right as we get more and more
signal and it increases from bottom to
top as we get lower and lower
background levels to give you an example
of how background can affect contrast
tremendously stars are actually out
during the day you just can't see them
because the sunlight is so bright and
that it's sky is so bright but once that
brightness goes away and day turns to
night the stars that were the same
signal they were before are suddenly
visible because the background is no
longer there so background can affect
contrast tremendously now that we
understand contrast let's talk about
what types of intensity values we're
going to display from an image so most
monitors and printers and computers
store images as eight bits of intensity
higher grade scientific cameras or if
you take a high dynamic or a range or
HDR photo you might store those images
as 16 bits or 16 bits as raw data but
most computers can only display 8 bits
of information at any one time so what
ranges of values of that 16 bits are you
going to actually choose to display well
if you have something that's really
bright you might choose the topmost bits
or the the brightest bits to display and
scale those to eight bits that your
monitor a computer to display if that
image is fairly dim you might take the
dimmest pixels in that image and stretch
them into the eight bits that your
monarch and monitor can display but that
same sort of transformation can also
apply to 8-bit images we can take a
range of those values from an 8-bit
image and choose which range to display
and on your monitor so in order to
understand what we're doing with this
let's talk about how we analyze image
intensity so there's actually a way to
plot all of the image intensities in
your image and this is called a
histogram it's a plot of intensity
values so what we're going to do is take
our mandrel example and that matrix of
numbers from that little tiny portion of
the muzzle and we're going to count the
intensities by range so let's take the
range of pixel values from 100 to 119 if
I count those out go through all that
and count out I get about 10 pixels from
that range if I now go from 120 to 139
and count all those up I get
ting if I count from 140 to 159 and
since these values there's only one of
those so it's a very small number from
160 to 179 I've got about 19 and etc etc
you can continue counting in these
binned ranges okay so what does that
give us if you'd look at those counts
those tally marks that looks kind of
like a graph turn that graph sideways
and plot it out for the entire image
going from low intensities on the left
or zero all the way up to 255 to the
highest intensity and we're gonna plot
the counts as a graph and this ends up
being called a histogram plot of all the
intensities so it's counts over the
entire range of intensities that are
possible so a histogram is actually a
very informative plot of what kind of
intensities are in our image so for
example for this histogram we can see
that there are very few black pixels and
there are very few white pixels and the
majority of these pixels are mostly gray
centered right about the center of this
image of the intensity values let's take
a look at another image so this is an
image of a bunch of boats and we can see
that there is a bunch of high number of
black pixels so those black pixels
correspond to the bottoms of those boats
and there's also a bunch of gray pixels
that correspond to the sea and the air
and most of the boat and a few little
wider and brighter pixels as well but
this gives us an indication of what kind
of intensity values our images contain
even color histograms can tell us
something so I can take all of the
intensities in the red channel the green
channel in the blue channel and plot
those individual histograms and so for
example in the highest values at 255 you
see a lot of red and just a little bit
of blue and no green and those
correspond to the bright red stripe
going down the center of the muzzle of
this on this mandrel just a little bit
below those there is some fairly bright
blue with no green and a tiny little bit
of red and blue and red together make up
magenta so this is the magenta and blue
stripes along the muzzle next to the
nose
a little bit farther or dimmer you can
see a bunch of green and a little bit of
red and very little blue and this
corresponds to the yellow whiskers
because red and green together make
yellow so we can get a little bit of
information from color from histogram
and you can do the same sorts of plots
of intensities of color so how do we use
these histogram plots to bring out
information from an image well let's
draw a line going from the bottom left
to the top right corner of this
histogram and we're going to use this
original histogram as the input and
we're going to create an output
histogram corresponding to the image
that we want so the bottom or zero
correspond in the input corresponds to
serial in the output and 255 on the
input corresponds to 255 the output and
we called this transformation a linear
map we're going linearly from 0 to 255
on the input and that maps two images or
values from 0 to 255 on the output side
but what happens if we stretch this line
or change the slope of this line so
let's take the minimum and raise it up
and the maximum and lower it down we
flee stretch that image we essentially
are narrowing our contrast range to
what's actually in our image to the
values or brightness values that are
actually in our image so we can actually
make a better contrast image of this
mandrel but we don't have to stick to a
line we can also use a curve to describe
a transfer function from input to output
so you can use a curve to the bottom
right for instance to get rid of some of
the darker values while keeping some of
the brighter values or you can use a
curve to the upper left to boost the
darker values without really increasing
the bright values as much so we can use
these tools the histogram and these
transfer functions and our minimum or
maximum and our gamma to bring out
information and to get the most out of
our scientific images so let's use our
newfound knowledge of image intensity
values and histograms to try and bring
out some more information from some
scientific
images so we're going to be using the
free image manipulation program called
[ __ ] stands for the new image
manipulation program but most of the
other software packages you might run
across will have the same sort of
histogram manipulation screens that you
can use to bring out intensity
information and hidden information from
scientific images so I'm gonna use [ __ ]
and I'm going to drag one file on to
this image manipulation program up so
what we have here are a bunch of stars
taken against a black mount right so
let's see if we can bring out some other
information from this particular photo
so we're gonna go to the main histogram
window for adjusting and doing these
maps so there are two that we want to
talk about in camp we're gonna talk
about under the colors menu there's a
something called levels and there's
something called curves so these two
menu items right here will let us
manipulate the histogram so let's start
with levels
okay so levels shows a histogram of the
intensity values within this image right
so you can see this is our histogram we
going from dark pixels to bright pixels
and we're seeing a count of dark to
bright pixels now let's take a look
there are two basic comps and the first
thing I'm gonna do is take this maximum
value and drag it down all the way to
about where we start to see stuff well
guess what now we can start to see we've
got these dim stars in the background
and by just changing the intensity
levels we're able to bring out some of
the information that was hidden to our
eyes in this image so we can now see the
milky way we can see now see more
galaxies more stars and we can start to
see this mountain right here
let's bring the intensity down a little
bit more ok now the stars are really
bright and now we're starting to see a
little bit of this mountain so it looks
like if we look at this histogram most
of this line most of this comes from the
mountain and most of this hump
comes from the stars so we could bring
out the stars at the expense of the
mountain and remember if we drop the
background down we can get a little bit
better contrast so if we want to focus
on the stars and the Milky Way galaxy
portions sitting right across your image
we can bring the bottom a little bit up
and that decreases the apparent
background so I'm just gonna zoom in
I'm gonna hit plus on the keyboard and
we can start to see individual stars all
right
so we brought out some hidden
information in this image let's take a
look at a couple of other images so
let's take a look at a daytime image and
let's see if we can actually see some
stars in this and I bet you I think we
can see anything inside this image so
I'm gonna bring up again colors levels
and right now this bright stuff here is
showing the sky and the brightest
portions of the image but this histogram
is really really dim it's really hard to
see because the counts are linear
there's a little button up here and a
lot of your software programmers will
have something like this it makes up
what's called a logarithmic histogram so
this basically expands the histogram out
so you can see more of what's happening
so again now this logarithmic histogram
if I drag down great okay so we can't
see anything at the dark because the
bright image is just too bright okay so
we're not gonna really be able to pull
out let's try dragging the bottom back
up okay let's change the background
below in the background well we still
can't see stars in this image and that's
fine they're just it's too much too
little contrast in our original image
but let's do one more thing let's go to
colors they reset right quick just to
get back to normal and I'm gonna go to
color curves okay so this remember that
transfer function we talked about well
we can decrease or increase the minimum
and turn a little bit more black you can
also change to a curve
we could potentially make this mountain
a little bit more contrasty by changing
the intensity curve and the fun thing
about this is that you can actually put
multiple curves on your on your color
curve you can put multiple inflection
points okay but now that we understand
what's happening gives us a little bit
of a better grasp of what we're doing
with these sorts of intensity
transformation curves all right so let's
see if we can bring out something else
let's start with another stars image so
let's drag another image onto here okay
so now this image is from a 16-bit or
RAW format so the previous image right
here was only eight bits and let me take
a look let's go to image precision and
this is an 8-bit integer image okay
let's go take a look on this this if we
look at image precision assess 16-bit so
there's more information in this image
than there was in the previous image
okay so let's bring up our color levels
again and take a look and remember I
still got this is the normal histogram
actually let's go back to this linear
Instagram versus the logarithmic
histogram let me click on the linear
histogram right here okay so again we're
seeing two humps one is a black hump and
one is a slightly less black up so let's
bring up our bring our maximum down and
again we can start to see the stars
right so we can see a lot of interesting
things in here and again I can bring the
minimum up and to just increase the
contrast of the sky this night sky so
now we're seeing a little bit better
contrast here of the night sky but we're
still washing this out a little bit
let's drop this back down so a little
bit of sunset left at this twilight
image but remember this little hump
right here let's move our minimum and
maximum to span that hump and guess what
look at that now we see the mountain in
essentially like daylight conditions and
the sixteen bits of information what
that means is that we getting a loop
we're getting a lot more shades when
we're
looking at this tiny little range of our
input values we're getting a lot more
shades out because there's a more
information stored in the 16-bit image
okay let's take a look at another image
let's see if we can pull out more star
images from let's say an eclipse so this
is the Sun during the Eclipse and this
is not quite a full Eclipse yet and
again this image if we take a look at
the precision this is an 8-bit image so
there might not be a lot hidden inside
this image but we're gonna try anyway
let's go to levels and it looks like
there's just a tiny little bit of
information down here let's switch to a
logarithmic histogram in reality this is
logarithmic there's not much information
right here
but I can still drag this maximum down
okay and now the corona from the Sun is
peeking out a little bit more we're
seeing more of that but in reality we're
not really seeing much in terms of stars
this image was just the raw data it was
just too dim to get at the stars behind
this image so let's try another a clicks
Eclipse image that's a little bit
farther along back up okay so this is at
a full Eclipse and now this Corona is
really bright because this image was
taken at a much longer exposure still
it's an 8 bit image but let's see what
we can bring out with the levels okay
let's bring our maximum down okay and
now we're starting to see some things
and here's something else I want to
point out so we're starting to see some
spots in the background and I am gonna
have to zoom up to take a look at these
ok so and I can hold down the spacebar
and use this to drag our image around I
can use the plus key to zoom in and a
minus key to zoom out and the spacebar
and dragging this come on ok so now
we're starting to see blobs right here
this is a star you can zoom up on it
and I can tell that this is likely a
star because it takes up more than one
pixel you notice in the background area
right here there's a bunch of noise and
this is what happens with
low-light images your camera's just
generate a lot of noise and that tends
to be really low values of intensity but
it's still there when you're blowing up
the intensity like this that noise comes
right out but and you'll notice that
there are single points of noise right
here it looks like individual pixels
might be bright surrounded by darker
things and that tends that's an
indication that what that is is noise
things that tend to look square whereas
do you see this right here this blob
that is likely a star this blob right
here is likely a star because it takes
up more than one pixel it's taking up a
few pixels so that is a collection of
photons a very dim collection of photons
but a collection of photons nonetheless
that indicate that what you're looking
at is a star and not noise so again
there's a little there's less clarity to
this image because the signal here is
very weak and the noise is very strong
okay so now let's look at a biological
image something a little bit less
astronomy so this is an image of a
flower and let's see if we can find
something else on this flower so I'm
gonna go to color level let's take a
look at our histogram it's a little bit
low so I'm gonna switch to a logarithmic
so I could see more of the values right
here okay and typically what I do when
I'm looking in a scientific image is I
will play around with the minimum and
I'll drag that up and down and see if I
can see anything new
no there's something that's poking out
and I can drag them back the maximum
down a little bit and see if I could see
anything at the dim portions okay
so let's drag up this minimum and you're
starting to see something with a little
bit more contrast looks like there's a
caterpillar on this flower and we can
bring it out with this with just
manipulating the histogram and this
transfer function the input versus
output levels similarly if let's take a
look at these petals so I'm going to
zoom up on a petal right
and these petals are fairly dark they're
darker than the center of the flower
let's do not go so the pedals here
surrounding and even this black space
the the flower is really bright but
sometimes if you're looking for
something really bright in an image it's
going to overwhelm the dark stuff that
you might be interested in seeing so I'm
gonna drag this top portion down and see
if I can bring out some detail at the
darker levels now at the darker levels
you're starting to see potentially
caverna miss flower yeah and you can see
the veins on the flower the flower
petals a little bit clearer so sometimes
and let's just compare that to drag me
all the way up okay so sometimes the
information you're looking at is hidden
in dark information and you can
sacrifice bright pixels and bright
portions of your data in order to look
at the dimmer stuff so that will
hopefully give you a little bit of an
idea of how to bring information out of
scientific photos to look for the hidden
side in what the images you took and to
understand what image intensity levels
and histograms and these transfer
functions can show you with scientific
images thank you for joining us for this
tutorial in our imaging science series
with the MIT Museum and Koch Institute
we'd love to see your stunning science
photos if you'd like to share them with
us you can show them on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram and use the hashtag MIT em
imaging science to share those with us
at the end of this program so on June
20th will be holding a webinar to look
at what makes a great science photo and
some of those submissions have a chance
to be featured during that webinar for
more information on the imaging science
program other tutorials and other
information and resources please visit
the MIT Museum website at the link below
and you will find a list of our other
resources as part of the Imaging Science
program